Breaking news, overnight from Facebook, eleven thousand,...
…eleven thousand jobs have been cut at the social media giant, Meta.
Mark Zuckerberg shared a lengthy message with employees.
Our chief business correspondent, Rebecca Jarvis, has the very latest on this.
Rebecca, good morning, that's a lot of jobs.
A lot of jobs, TJ, good morning.
The largest job cuts in the company's history.
Eleven thousand people, 13% of Facebook's parent company, Meta's workers...
…will lose their jobs beginning today.
And in that lengthy note you referenced, the founder and CEO, Mark Zuckerberg,...
…apologizing to his employees, writing in this note...
…that it's one of the most difficult changes he's had to make.
That he is owning this decision.
He's explaining that he made missteps.
He overinterpreted the pandemic, thought that things would continue...
...to improve and grow for the company and that they overhired...
…during the pandemic, and now they have to cut staff.
We've heard similar stories from other major tech companies,...
…recently from Microsoft, to Netflix, to Twitter this week,...
…where companies are downsizing and that raises a lot of questions...
…about the jobs market which overall appears robust.
Historically low unemployment, 3.7 percent.
Guys, this raises questions about the ripple effect, the spillover effect...
…of these employee losses in tech.
Could it add to other areas of the economy?